[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump's banana Republicans
have proposed that White House press
briefings be moved out of the
presidential mansion and held next door
at the executive office building and why
should you care for one damned minute
Reince Priebus says it's a great thing
because the result would be quote about
quadrupling the amount of reporters that
can cover the White House and certainly
that sounds like a wonderful
intensification on the bright shining
light of a democratic Free Press on the
operation of a commander-in-chief and
his noble staff the more the better
right just the way it works in Russia a
giant crowd of reporters screaming for
the leaders attention making signs
indicating what organization they belong
to and even signs and props indicating
what questions they intend to ask some
of them showing exactly the kind of
objectivity and respectful skepticism a
free press is supposed to bring to the
coverage of government at its highest
levels and yes she's a self-described
journalist at a Putin news conference
holding a picture of Putin ripping off
his shirt to indicate he's actually
Superman we are just a few steps removed
from the contestants trying to get MC
Monty halls attention during the taping
of the old game show let's make a deal
though I would never want to insult
anybody in a comparison among Vladimir
Putin Donald Trump and Monty Hall I have
respect for Monty Hall look I don't know
the last time anything at a White House
news conference or anything done by a
White House correspondent actually
contributed anything measurable to the
coverage of a president not since Sam
Donaldson used to make news by bellowing
questions at Ronald Reagan and Reagan
condemning himself by refusing to answer
them I also think that a traditional
journalism contributes in any way to the
prevention of dictatorship here now it
will be by the grunt work fact-checking
the White House news conferences and
revealing legislation and departmental
orders and checking legalities and
confronting an administration's lies
with facts the next Woodward and
Bernstein will get there not at the news
conferences but by skill at filing
Freedom of Information Act requests but
the idea of quadrupling the amount of
reporters that can cover the White House
is a Trojan horse with a lot of Trojans
in it firstly there is the Putin like
spectacle the
the room the more room for staffers and
hangers on and for want of a better term
Trump plants Trump gave this stunt away
at last week's news conference he packed
the place with people applauding for him
and they have as much right to be at a
presidential news conference as when
people booing him and that amount of
people is none quadrupling in the number
so-called reporters at the news
conferences and you have suddenly
created another stop on the Trump
perpetual campaign rally tour quadruple
the number of so-called reporters at the
news conferences and you suddenly make
it easier to ignore the reporters with
actual questions as opposed to the ones
carrying signs showing Trump wearing a
Superman shirt quadruple the number of
so-called reporters at the news
conferences and you suddenly change from
difficult to impossible any coordinated
action to prevent Trump repeating the
other stunts he used in New York last
week singling out an attacking one
reporter the way the bully picks out one
kid from the crowd to beat up while the
others say thank goodness it wasn't me
and they continue to participate in the
farce the press court should have walked
out then and there but all that would
have happened then would have been more
questions from Trump staffers quadruple
the number of so-called reporters at the
news conferences and you lose any sense
of who is asking the questions and what
their motivations are you may add
Horrocks news as Fox News viewers app
horny you don't have any doubts as to
why we are asking what we are asking
either of us and you don't have any
doubts about whether or not we have been
planted there it is in retrospect so
absurd as to be almost unbelievable and
almost forgotten his name was Jeff
Gannon or so he said and he represented
something called Talon news and in early
2003 the Bush White House press office
began issuing him day passes to its news
conferences but then on January 26 2005
President Bush held his own news
conference and there was Gannon
lootellan news asking him about Senate
Democratic leaders quote how are you
gonna work with people who seemed to
have divorced themselves from reality
within two weeks the whole stunt
collapsed Jeff Gannon was actually
jamesgu Curt and the closest thing he
had come to journal
before he began asking friendly
questions at the White House was having
his naked pictures appear on a series of
gay escort websites Ganon stopped
writing for his site the White House
never gave him another press credential
his Tallinn news organization was
tracked back to the owner of the website
GOP USA and then the Tallinn site was
shuttered it was also later revealed but
never convincingly explained how Ganon
slash duckers had learned of an internal
government memo about the outing of the
CIA operative Valerie Plame and just as
all this was playing out federal records
were revealed showing the Bush
administration had paid a man named
Armstrong Williams $240,000 Williams had
a syndicated newspaper column and in
exchange for that money he was supposed
to write positive articles about bushes
No Child Left Behind program and to try
to convince other African American
journalists to do the same the Bush
administration's attempt at media
manipulation including literally buying
good coverage was amateurish compared to
what we can expect from Trump and his
White House chief strategist the former
campaign boss and head of the bright
part propaganda site Steve Bannon why
was it that the gut Curt Gannon and
Williams scams didn't work they didn't
work because they were too easy to spot
in a crowd solution make the crowd
bigger move the White House press
briefings next door and his Reince
Priebus says you can quadruple the
amount of reporters that can cover the
White House so what if you don't know if
they're being paid to ask softball
questions or to cheer or just to serve
as more useful idiots at a trump rally
it's only the end of the First Amendment
oh and by the way the guy the bush he's
paid for the positive newspaper columns
Armstrong Williams he's still around he
works with a dr. ben Carson and when
that nominee for Secretary of Housing
endorsed Trump in March 2016 the
endorsement was confirmed by Armstrong
Williams resist peace